San Francisco weather what are you
talking Gate Bridge Oh Lord look the
sake of argument will say there's only
four possibilities it's sunny cloudy
rainy it's foggy and all you got to say
is okay what's the probability of these
equally probable law is one more light
than the other and for the sake of
argument let's say this in San Francisco
you do get all of these it's amazing
every single one in about an equal
proportion roughly so let's say it's a
quarter and a quarter and the quarter
and the quarter and all those have you
been through high school statistics now
if these are probabilities add them all
together it's got to add up to one
one is certainty 100% so four causes one
let's say therefore that here am I in
San Francisco and here is my friend in
Reno and we have got an electronic
buzzer you know one of those
old-fashioned things that you see in a
wartime move is where you tap out a
Morse code or whatever but this is gonna
be very very simple that's an agreed
time in the day I've got to transmit the
state of the weather in San Francisco
from my weather station to the guy in
Reno as compactly as possible because
this is the early days of electronic
transmission and each bit cost me $1,000
to send okay okay so what's the minimum
number of bits I need because going to
encode it in noughts and ones well you
look at this you said well it's Forster
it's they're equally probable how about
something like this 0 0 for sunny 0 1
for cloudy 1 0 for rainy and one one for
foggy for completely separate
distinguishable possibilities right so
if it's Sun a guy
just goes tap tap two short dots for two
zeros and the guy at Reno knows for only
$2,000 it is sunny at the Madison
Francisco can you do any better than
that
no you can't you've got four equally
probable things there's no way in the
world that losslessly you can get better
than that
yeah however our sounds very defeatist
well it is boo but you asked is there a
limit and there is so long as you want
it lossless there is a limit and you
can't get below it it's the entropy
limit and those who've done chemistry in
physics will know you can't beat it all
right
however if only things were more
predictable this is not quite true but
he's virtually true Sahara Desert I'm
not gonna ask you to draw a picture for
that probability the probability here is
one it is always sunny in the Sahara
Desert so if I'm got my Sahara Desert
key pad here and I've got a
transatlantic line to Reno Nevada where
they gather all of this data how many
bits of information do I need to send to
get that message Torino the answer is if
the weather never changes you don't need
to send any information at all it's
always sunny why I asked but if you want
to be absolutely sure let's just say
send a zero to be sure okay send a zero
cosine send a zero if it's sunny you
didn't really need to because it always
is that's cost you well but of course
you released a thousand dollars to send
it again but yeah one bit one bit will
be more than ample actually the
information theory answer is zero bits
because if it's certain you don't need
to tell anybody this will kill you you
can you can edit this out but you do the
maths ones then we edit nothing out here
well I do the movements all right okay
so what we what we remember of course is
that one quarter
is the same as one over two squared
which is the same as two to the power
minus two number of bits you need equals
probability of it happening times log of
the probability of it happening - if you
take log to the base 2 of 2 to the minus
2 the answers - to turn it positive -
what the log of that probability is
telling you is the number of bits you
need minimum so there is so for any
piece of information there is a minimum
number of bits yeah so if one of these
was an AIDS how many bits would you need
to encode although why don't you tell me
well right if if there were eight things
right then what you could say is that 2
to the power minus 3 is 1/8 so it will
be a 3 bit code are you auditioning for
a place on numberphile here we've got
this minimum for a piece of information
is that only on the playing field of the
system we use at the moment this zeros
and ones I mean is it possible if we you
came up with a new way of storing and
transmitting information it would be a
game-changer for a zeros and ones no if
we leaving aside weird quantum effects
who knows what might come out of that as
of the real world that we have it this
is just it's a it's a showstopper you
can't get beyond this entropy limit when
I was taught about entropy this
irreversible sort of minimum that you
can get when you do it from the point of
view of physics and chemistry they love
saying things like this and it's sort of
works is you've got a diamond close to
absolute zero yeah that is a very low
entropy system low entropy means it's
ultra predictable
there's the crystal is vibrating but
only just you know where it is it's not
moving high entropy is when the
probabilities are smeared out you don't
know where it is so another time you get
a gas with
millions of molecules ooming here there
and everywhere that's a very mixed
random high entropy system and I can see
how I take the view there's a lot easier
instead of starting with 10 to the 23
molecules in a gas start with 4 weather
states in San Francisco and you get the
idea and then you can transfer it to
physics and chemistry anselmo in
physical chemistry and fourthly we've
got to use natural logs and you've got
to take a summation not over four states
right but over ten to the 24 because you
see here I definitely can't figure that
one no here you can say average number
of bits I need is the sum over all these
P log P s so it's 1/4 times 2 bits for
that one plus 1/4 times 2 bits plus 1/4
times 2 bits plus 1/4 times the tubers
Wow isn't this amazing the answer is
that the average massive length is 2
bits but if those were skewed a bit you
can kind of instinctively see what you
would do if one of these became a half
you want to give it a short code right
because because if what so if it was
sunny more often why would say well
let's make our code for something short
and some skewer whether like a tornado
so like I'll make it yeah exactly so
like it was a half your theory here
would say that's 2 to the minus 1 hey
let's try a 1 bit code there and let's
use 2 bit codes for the others so you
could end up with something if it's like
Los Angeles is this reputed to be that's
smoggy and that's sunny that's rain
that's cloud well you could then start
saying oh well how about devoting the
clothes 0 to denoting smoggy yeah
because it's more common because it's
more common anybody who's watched World
War 2 movies and people tapping out
Morse codes a lot of people I'm sure
will know that the most common letter e
has got the shortest code it's a single
dot in most in most code whereas Ed is
quite long and so on so it applies you
know all the ways
through this so what you could say
therefore is if I'm gonna start with a
zero for smoggy then I better not
confuse matters by starting a longer
code for any of these with zero right
let's start more with one so let's say
something like 1-0 sunny but then you
say well I better not start either of
these with one zero otherwise things
will get confused so let's start them
with one one yeah but the trouble is if
one one have been running out of what I
can use for cloud can you see it have to
say 1 1 0 and 1 1 1 because you've got
to be able to uniquely decode it and if
you're not very careful you will end up
with something that can't be uniquely
unscramble I suppose to save telephone
costs you send two weeks whether all at
once 7 things one after another
how can you uniquely unscramble it into
being these it happens with telephone
numbers it happens to me at home this
and my telephone number has to have the
prefix property I live in a village
where my telephone number is a 5 digit
code
unfortunately some people in the village
have got 6 digit codes yes
telephone codes have the prefix property
they connect the moment they've been
unambiguously satisfied so if you have a
legal 5 digit telephone code it cannot
be the prefix of a longer code because
the telephone exchange goes bang and
connects you the moment you've given
something sensible yeah the trouble then
is that the o card who delivery system
doesn't understand this and thinks
everybody's got to have six digits so do
you know what I do so when you're
ordering groceries you deliberately
number I said the very end thinking
about your good yeah someone won't
accept your phone number true had any
digits just add n digits the air for
weather condition was more common like
sunny weather in California you give
that a shorter code you save information
did the people that invented the JPEG
format or do other people that are doing
compression use probabilities but today
so do they know that blue is more common
in pictures or how do they you know it
doesn't quite come down to that it's
more in the JPEG standard it's more as
it were spatially aware as well as color
aware in terms of what it's doing but
yeah in one respect or another
probabilities is the root of all of this
and like I say that's particularly true
if you want lossless compression because
you run up against unstoppable entropy
limits about how far you can compress
and not lose anything in in the
compression it's 18 megabytes and let me
say again 18 megabytes not 80 gigabytes
and it's in this huge package they start
the bottom we take the pivot everything
on the Left goes behind it